you ever miss your tiger huh yeah
i have kids and small kids now he
wouldn't like that but yeah i miss my
cat
i could imagine i couldn't imagine yeah
they show up in my car do you ever think
about getting another one no i have my
kids a little yeah your older kids don't
mike did you older your older kids were
there when you had your wife yeah they
liked them they loved them yeah
wouldn't you how long how long did you
have to get rid of him before uh i'm
like 14 years old is he still alive no i
think he died they don't live long
what's his name or her name [ __ ]
kenya kenya
how many pounds of meat did she eat
she didn't eat a lot but she she ate
constantly she had a lot constantly you
know you couldn't feel it like one time
she
she likes to eat a lot
but she um chicken
and put more chicken in there i have
some horse horse what they love more
than anything the horse of the chicken
what is it about the horse meat that
makes it tight tastes beautiful
beautiful do you ever taste sauce before
i think maybe
my heart out
what do they call horses like the
grocery store
oh
i never seen that watch me if it comes
it's not like like a loaf of bread but
it's um it's cold they keep it in the
freezer and it's big they just cause
it's hard because i know like deer meat
is like venison yeah that's beautiful
too yeah i think i've had
um oak um
the ox is good too alexa oh yeah i love
some moss too yeah yeah
[Music]